all right guys
bang bang i've got barney here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
uh thanks for having me absolutely let's
just jump right into it you've been
working on decentralized
derivatives uh before we understand what
that is and why it's important maybe we
can just start out with
uh decentralized finance in general how
do you evaluate the space why is this
important
yeah so the way i think about this you
know i got interested in the whole
space you know back when bitcoin was
kind of pretty new
uh and then i got sort of excited again
when ethereum came out and particularly
the idea of creating tokens and
and sort of decentralizing the financial
system and the movement of value
and i spent most of my career working in
you know kind of traditional finance
and one of the things you learned in
that is that you know controlling the
money itself is like
you know a tiny percentage of actually
the day-to-day use of finance and so
in order to actually take control of
finance decentralize it allow for
innovation and freedom
you really need to decentralize the
financial products and and trading that
people do and you need to make those
things non-custodial as well
so really i see d5 is kind of absolutely
necessary for bitcoin and
and you know cryptocurrency in general
to be successful
and so when you think about that today
how far into that journey are we are we
still just starting have we made
considerable progress
are we at the finish line we're far from
the finish line
um i think i think we've made
considerable progress like i mean i
think it's amazing
to see the the innovation and the pace
of innovation and also the amount of
money
because that really brings people
building and investing uh into the d5
space so i think we've made really
considerable progress especially the
last couple of years
maybe after a few false starts around
the time of ether delta in the first
texas but i think we've made really good
progress
um we're seeing great stuff but i also
think there's a long way to go like if
you
if you look at the the scale of trading
the speed of trading
the low cost of trading actually on the
you know the big
centralized platforms the stock
exchanges and the fx markets and stuff
like that
you know we're a long way to go before
we can actually rival that with the
technology but
you know i firmly believe we can get
there and so when you think about how
far we've come i think that there's a
number of uh kind of improvements that
you've identified in terms of
uh d5 in general still needs to work on
to kind of get to that next level
what are some of those improvements that
are top of mind
yeah so probably like you know some of
the biggest ones right now are
you obviously the fees are a problem
because if you're looking at
ethereum fees right now and you look at
the volume of trading not just
not you know people compared to visa but
visa is actually a tiny fraction of the
volume of orders and trades
in the financial world and there's no
way at the moment that we can do that at
all let alone at a reasonable fee
uh where traditional finance is doing it
really cheaply so that scaling is
is one aspect and you know there are
some there are some answers there that
are showing promise and then
the other big one for me is probably
around well you know fairness
um and that's where you have the mev and
the front running and things like that
because if someone else
is sort of adversarially able to take
value from you every time you
venture into d5 unless you're super
careful then that just makes it really
difficult to get involved
and it removes some of the freedom you
have probably the final one is risk like
you know at the moment there are a lot
of
implicit risks because we have a lot of
code that's been written not
not battle tested and we don't see you
know we don't actually see how things
connect together yet so those are
probably
probably the three biggest and one of
the aspects of decentralized finance
that i think most people immediately
think is the decentralized element of it
but there's also this element of
non-custodial exchanges not custodial
lending
maybe we can start there uh with the
non-custodial exchange and you can kind
of talk through it's like
why is that important and then how
exactly do these work so for somebody
who's not super technical that wants to
understand how a non-custodial exchange
just how would you describe that to them
yeah so you know i guess the the simple
high-level description of a
non-custodial exchange is that
um in in the traditional world and most
of the time
if you're doing something with money you
know that some
product that someone's offering then or
something that someone's built you're
giving them the money and letting them
do that you know and if you go
take out a product with a bank you give
the bank your money and you trust them
or maybe you trust your government's
insurance scheme that compensates you if
the bank goes bankrupt but
you're trusting someone to look after
your money and not to lose it all and
you know that sort of works for large
companies and for small amounts of money
if you're a consumer putting your money
in a bank
and the government's gonna guarantee
that maybe you trust that but maybe in
some countries you don't
the advantage that you know
decentralization gives us and
it doesn't always give us this by
default because you can design
decentralized systems that are also
custodial
but if you design the systems the right
way the advantage is that you can have
people design
if you will products that are kind of
built you know code which lets you have
access to that financial functionality
without needing to give your money to
someone else so that
you know if someone has reviewed the
code if you take on that product
if you start using this system then you
don't have to trust this person not to
lose your money and it's kind of the
same with you know whether you leave
your
your bitcoin on an exchange or whether
you leave it on a on a cold wallet or a
ledger or something like that and i
think you know partly it's
it's sort of the way of of this space
and the ideology and the reason
we do a lot of these things is to to
grant ourselves those freedoms and
control over our money and our
our future but also it enables a lot of
innovation because it means that smaller
players can create things
without you worrying they might
disappear if something is non-custodial
and so when you think about these
non-custodial exchanges starting
there's a lot of benefits right which
you just described and kind of a lot of
things that prevent them from doing bad
stuff
but one of the challenges to getting
started is around liquidity
and how do they basically get folks to
provide liquidity on an exchange
or for lending uh what's the state of
liquidity
in d5 and then what are maybe the
tactics people are using
that work to kind of bootstrap liquidity
versus the tactics that
maybe people thought worked but actually
have proven not to be as effective
yeah so it's a great question about
liquidity there um
and i think it's one of the things that
people don't necessarily appreciate is
that in
traditional finance actually there's a
role that the exchanges and you know
the uh the service providers have even
though they're sort of centralized
entities and we also think or
centralized is bad they actually carry
out that role you know they make a lot
of profit but they use some of that
profit to go and find liquidity and to
do deals and to take on the risk of
there being
a lack of liquidity and you know some of
them the early mistakes were simply to
ignore
that role and think centralized bad but
not replace it with anything
uh people have got a little bit better
now so they've worked out that actually
you know trading creates value and some
of that value needs to go
to attract liquidity but we're also you
know
there's a couple of things going on that
mean that you know we're doing things
that might not be sustainable and
you know the first one of those is
you've got a lot of investment money and
a lot of token issuance you know things
are going up everyone's
you know the price is going up because
everyone has a huge
speculative view of the future which
means that you can issue tokens and give
them to liquidity providers
eventually that won't be sustainable
this stuff becomes infrastructure
you've got to make it happen really
cheaply and it's got to be really
efficient so
you know that kind of vc money and just
token issuance forever just to pay for
liquidity is gonna
it's gonna dry up at some point and that
relates to the other problem which i
think we still have is the
the capital efficiency of liquidity and
you know
right now the uh the people offering it
are in a kind of nice position if you
like got a lot of people kind of
huddling they're
huddling their coins and they don't have
that much to do so they're just kind of
like yeah i want some yields so
it doesn't really matter like if you you
know when you look at i think you know
even uni swap and acknowledge this with
their v3 announcement when you look at
the percentage of the funds in a pool
that are actually
supporting prices that have any
realistic chance of happening it's like
a really small percentage because
most of the funds support the rest of
the curve which are very far away from
the price so if you think about that
from an efficiency point of view
the amount of capital you need stuck in
that pool to provide the liquidity for
the prices that are happening is much
much higher
compared to what it would be on an order
book based exchange for instance where
you're really supporting the biz and
authors right around the price and so
as people get as there's more
competition both in terms of
decentralized exchanges but also with
other ways to earn yield and other
things to do with your money
people are going to start to get really
picky about this because if the vcs
aren't throwing money at them
and they can get that revenue and that
yield more efficiently somewhere else
then you know it's hard to argue why
they're going to put the liquidity
somewhere so i think we're going to have
a sort of arms race in terms of
efficiency
and yield you can get and we've already
seen it sort of starting with the yield
farming and the automated balance thing
and
everything going on but i think that's
going to heat up massively once we get
to kind of like the scaling solutions
and the faster
more efficient trading networks because
at the moment everyone's super
constrained by you know
ethereum and it's kind of you know it's
block time and the simplicity of the
algorithms you can do so you can't
there's not that much room for
innovation but
i think that's going to change massively
and so we're going to see a big race for
efficient liquidity
and what do you think is kind of the end
game there
does this become so turn key that people
know how to elicit
liquidity folks understand how to kind
of yield farm or move liquidity around
that eventually this can all be
automated and it just is like an
automated finance system and
there won't have to be all this human
decision making and choice uh
or will there always be some new way
some new mechanism
uh and people are really gonna have to
pay attention and become experts in this
so i think it's a bit of both actually
so i think there will always be room for
people coming up with algorithms and
improving them
you know to offer better liquidity or
more efficiency in a certain place and
and that's never going to be always one
one size fits all you know even if
you're just talking about simple amms
different curves work better for stable
coins than for volatile coins for
instance and so
you know even in that case you might
you're going to have tweaks and new
algorithms and improvements all the time
but equally i think there's a lot of
room for people to get passive income
and there's a lot of room for automation
so
you're actually either giving you're
giving your money to a dao and
effectively having them invested in
liquidity or having algorithmic
allocation the other thing i think is
really interesting is turning liquidity
into a market itself and making it
tradable so
what's better than automation by an
algorithm is automation by a market
quite often you know markets are
fantastic resource allocators and so
once we kind of have a
standardized way to value liquidity
across disparate assets
so you can kind of see what's the value
of a unit of liquidity on market and on
market b and on platform c
then you start to get to a point where
you actually you're automatically
allocating liquidity in the same way
that you're
allocating resources in markets and then
it becomes super efficient
and so when you think about uh liquidity
when it comes to derivatives maybe let's
talk a little bit about
uh kind of the current state of
derivatives before you guys come along
uh just how do these work how
decentralized are they and what's like
the pro and cons
of uh all of the new derivative uh kind
of mechanisms that are being built in d5
yeah so um you know right now our
um between c5 and d5 are really really
different you know in on the centralized
side you can take
so much leverage that it's bad for you
you know you can take 100 x leverage on
on bitmex or wherever and and be erect
before you finish clicking the button um
or you can go on to one of the platforms
like synthetics then play
pay two three four five six seven times
more than the notional value of your
position yes you go from 100x
leverage to you know minus seven x you
know it's one over seven x you know you
actually get negative
less than one leverage um so really the
difference between the two right now is
really huge and
it's huge because of the risk of um you
know liquidations and closeouts it's
huge because of the
risk management and the algorithms
needed to do those kind of things
and it's also huge because of the
liquidity point as well you know um you
mentioned some liquidity on derivatives
and it's a bit different to liquidity on
uh spot markets on a spot market once
the trade is done everyone's happy you
know
so uni swap is despite being a little
less efficient maybe than a very liquid
order book in in many cases unit swap is
is very similar to a a spot exchange
because you can make it
make a trade as long as you're happy
with the price it's done
the thing about that is it doesn't take
any effort to provide the liquidity
because
the trade's done once it's done with um
with derivatives once you take on a
trade you've got a position and that
derivative has a lifetime and it matures
or settles eventually or in a purpose
case it never settles
and so if you as a liquidity provider or
if the pool ends up with a position
and that position is highly leveraged
you as a liquidity fighter all the pool
can go bankrupt and so
you know there are a number of solutions
in amms to kind of allocating these
things and allowing a pool to take a
an inventory position there's obviously
the traditional solution of active
management of those things there are
some interesting new
new working combinations and you know
actually we've been looking at
similarly you know how to do hybrid
order books with both um
both amms and order books and how to
work out the uh
the kind of you know that that liquidity
story for derivatives
and so then when you think about the
decentralized derivatives
um and you start to kind of push further
into what you guys are actually building
uh what are the things that you look and
you say okay this is what we're building
on this is why it's better or this is
why it's an improvement on the legacy
kind of mechanisms that have been built
yeah
so um you know obviously liquidity is
one part of that we have a
pretty sophisticated liquidity algorithm
and one of the things we look at with
that is
incentivizing liquidity in the right way
and you know the way i sort of look at
this is
you should be you should be incentivized
to provide liquidity that's valuable to
the market which in general means
liquidity that trades
because if it doesn't it's not that
valuable you should also be incentivized
to take risks so if you
create a new market and make it
available to people
the protocol ought to reward you for
doing that if you took a risk and if you
maybe you know
maybe you put money up in time and that
market might not succeed
and it ought to reward you much more
than someone who finds a really liquid
btc usd market and thinks hey i'm going
to provide a little
you know slither of a percent of extra
liquidity to that market and so
you know you need to reward the early
risk takers and you need to reward the
people who create the most
trading values so that's one one area we
look at um
another area we look at is around
performance you know we think that
um the kind of the block time that you
see on ethereum but also
the constraints of you know the actual
complexity of contracts that you can
have are
quite limiting even for spot markets but
the derivatives we think they are
you know just a real problem and then
you know we thought it was essential to
eradicate like mev and and front running
from from blockchain based to
centralized trading
and when you start to think about the
types of people who use
your protocol your decentralized
derivatives versus some of the other
types of derivatives available
are they the exact same types of folks
or do you tend to
kind of incentivize or collect a
different group of people
i think in the long run we're you know
everyone's going after the same groups
of people but i think that
the design decisions and the order you
build things will will affect sort of
who's interested in it right now you
know so when we when we first
first launched you know we're in a test
net right now when we first launched a
mainnet i expect you know the people
will
people involved in that will be the
people who are most interested in
perhaps relatively slightly less product
innovation in terms of some of the
some of the the funky stuff that's going
on in ethereum d5 but they're interested
in getting some of those
you know measurable quality improvements
here perhaps they're interested in
making some of their
their you know centralized trading
non-custodial and and taking the risk of
the centralized exchanges out of there
but then you know in the long term we
want to actually enable even faster
iteration but
i think ultimately everyone's going
after the same stuff but the the
choices we make will impact who uses it
first i guess
yeah what's up guys bang bang i hope
you're enjoying this conversation but
before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it and
when you think about the actual
technical architecture are you a
layer one a layer two a little bit of
both like
how do you just kind of think about that
yeah it's
a little bit of both is the answer and
you know the way
the way that we think about that is you
know firstly
we're not trying to take over the world
you know we're not attempting to say
in order to use our system you've got to
move all of d5 to our system and you've
got to use
issue your tokens on our system and do
everything else what we actually have
sort of said is
we really love d5 we want to integrate
with it and we want you to be able to
use
other d5 protocols on ethereum and on
ontario and on polkadot and wherever
as well as using what we're building and
so we don't actually have issuance of
tokens
on the vega platform at all what we
actually have instead
is uh bridges and so the first bridge is
to ethereum it's very much like using
something like uni swap you kind of you
know
pops metamask decide how many to deposit
authorize the transaction
and then you know once the number of
confirmations are through the vega
network recognizes your balance and you
can trade that eoc20 on vegas so
you know we really see ourselves as this
kind of in that sense we're a derivative
scaling layer to
you know for ethereum and other networks
but the network we're building in order
to do that and to do that in a secure
way and to be a non-custodial network is
also a kind of a layer one it's a
proof-of-stake network do you think more
people are gonna have to do this
or is this something that's unique to
you guys um
yeah i mean i think people will i think
because i think compound recently
announced that they're kind of building
their own chain
um you know and i suspect the reasons
are fairly similar and i think
you know one way to look at this is like
when you look at traditional finance you
know
people build websites using like
wordpress or whatever um
ruby on rails people in exchanges don't
build exchanges in wordpress or ruby on
rails right they
they build them fully optimized for
being centralized exchanges because
there's so much money moving around that
even a small optimization
is highly valuable and this is going to
be the same you know when you've got a
low-key use case with not that much use
or not that much value moving around you
know solidity and a
standardized network and scaling layer
and features is going to be great
but when you have as much money as there
is in global finance moving around and
there's much security at stake and
everything else
you know the advantage of optimizing and
building a sort of application specific
layer that's really optimized for that
application that can iterate faster
at being good at that application that
advantage just starts to to come home so
i think
i think you'll see this in in a number
of areas where there's a
clear demonstrated value i think you'll
see people start to specialize and build
you know really optimize things once we
see that the value is there
and then how do you think about
regulations around decentralized
derivatives is it just hey we take the
existing regulations and we just apply
them here
uh is that possible could there still be
the same level of enforcement and
understanding
uh or do we need some type of new rules
or an evolution or improvement of the
rules
yeah it's a good question and it's a
really hard one because i think
sometimes the existing regulations are
extremely unclear or not worded in a way
that they can easily be applied like
you have regulations that assume that
there is someone in control of a trading
platform and in fact
you know in these cases there is no
platform there are people connecting to
a network trading with each other
so you have some issues with how how
things are written and and you have that
kind of compounded by the fact that a
lot of the regulators are
you know reluctant to actually issue
issue full detailed guidance or update
regulations and so i do think
ultimately new rules or improvements to
rules or clarity will be beneficial
but i also think you can get quite a
long way applying the rules you have
all been a slightly different way and
what i mean is you know if something is
non-custodial if something is
decentralized
something is censorship resistant what
you have to do is you have to regulate
the users of the
of the system and you know the new york
stock exchange or the london stock
exchange they don't do that really they
they do but they rely on the platform as
an enforcer they kind of go and ask the
platform to do a bunch of things before
they let someone trade that
that doesn't really work in this sort of
decentralized world and so
you actually have to regulate the people
using it and you know i think people
will build a lot of tools for this and
and in general people should want to do
this you know most people early on in
crypto maybe thought that they weren't
going to do their taxes and then once
once the rules were released and they
realized they all kind of got two years
down the road and realized they had a
horrible headache because they'd been
sort of
you know just using crypto without
thinking about this and then went back
and went through everything and
worked it out and i think the same will
happen here and people will build tools
and people will build unchanged systems
to enable
people to ensure compliance but you can
you can sort of do that in a way where
it's kind of like the system's
decentralized you choose to obey the
rules like the speed limit right the
sign comes up and says
you've got to do 60 miles an hour or
less and you you decide whether you obey
that
but that's what you have to do and your
car's speeder helps you to know if you
are and i think
i think that's where we'll end up you
know you can obey whatever rules of
whatever country you're in if you need
to but it's going to have to be your
responsibility because you're the only
person who controls
your keys in your account and you're the
only person who even knows what country
you're in and so which rules they are
do you think that that poses a problem
from like an enforcement standpoint for
governments because they may not even
know
who you are where you are uh or whether
you're following the rules
yeah i mean i i think it's there's
there's definitely challenges in this
right like you know there's obviously
for businesses i think it's easier
because most businesses you know they're
gonna they're gonna file their taxes
they're gonna get audited and
they're gonna be pretty clear that they
wanna follow the rules so for businesses
and i think governments are going to
have a relatively easy ride because
you know ultimately the business is not
going to be
risking being shut down in pretty much
all cases and if it is it's sort of
perhaps behaving illicitly anyway i
think where the government start to
start to find things as sort of trouble
is it kind of increases the size of the
black market or the gray market of
kind of the area where individuals
particularly are able to do things and
you know kind of ignore the rules like
people who take cash for doing building
work and stuff you know and
they kind of just don't pay tax and try
and get away with it for a bunch of
stuff in in some cases and
i think you know that's the risk that
for the enforcement perspective is that
you have a bunch of people to whom
there's basically no cost
to deciding which rules to to obey and
which to ignore if they're kind of
individuals
and so you know that's and there's not
an easy one to
to get around and you know there's a
there's a large part of me which kind of
says well
maybe that maybe there are some things
that the government want to regulate
that
that people don't feel that they should
or have a right to you know kind of
kind of it's like you do the government
have a right to wander into your house
every so often and check that you're not
breaking any laws in there no
and so you know this kind of
surveillance by default to kind of
shut off shut off rule-baking before it
happens
is something governments have got used
to but it's not something that i think
is
is universally supported by people
particularly in this space so
it is going to present them a challenge
to work out how they deal with that and
and what the alternative is last
question i have for you before we get
into the rapid fire
is if we fast forward 10 or 20 years um
do we have 100 of derivatives globally
uh
being actually executed and kind of
entered into
and settled uh in a decentralized manner
is it 50 of the market is it 5
just how do you think about you know 10
to 20 years out from a
kind of market share standpoint and then
what is the path for us to get to that
point
yeah so so i think there's two bits of
this there's the underlying assets and i
think
i think once it comes you know think
about email versus like faxes and
letters
once it comes and everyone has it moving
money around using blockchains is going
to be
also obviously better that even if
they're done on centralized exchange
even if the new york stock exchange or
you know cme
do their derivatives still on a
centralized exchange i think the assets
are going to become more and more
blockchain based and i could easily see
very high penetration in you know like
15 20 years time
as for you know how much of the natural
derivatives are on fully decentralized
and non-custodial systems i think
that'll probably be less than
you know in in many cases and
particularly for established markets
there's not a particularly huge
imperative to move they're quite cheap
and they're quite efficient
unless you're locked out of that market
because it doesn't operate in your
jurisdiction
or unless you're trying to innovate and
create new markets that don't exist on
your products
so i think what we'll see is kind of you
know the market that's there will stay
there as you know taxis versus uber the
taxis are there
not realizing uber created a whole new
market and by making it cheaper more
accessible and actually grew the pie so
i think what happens is we grow the pie
and a huge portion of that growth
happens over in decentralized world
some things move over or some markets
become more global because we're able to
decentralize them
but in reality you know there's a huge
amount of momentum behind the
centralized market so i think there's
going to be
you know centralized alternatives at
least for the major markets for for a
good long time
yeah it's absolutely fascinating is
there anything that you've learned uh
in terms of uh in the last couple of
years that has really surprised you that
you didn't expect as you've been
building this
um yeah what surprised me um how long
ethereum two
took no i mean you know
it's been quite interesting watching the
last year or so like you know the number
of things sort of that maybe happened in
2017 you sort of see echoing and
and some some of those things happening
similarly again and some of the stuff
that goes on
i guess that slightly surprised me i i
thought things would be different and
they are definitely different but you
know i've seen seen some of the same
stuff
um the other thing i think that
surprised me is
the willingness people have to
experiment with their money and to
to put their money and their crypto
assets towards
effectively towards these experiments
where they could lose it all to help
move things forward and you know to bet
on
bet on things going well and you know
that when we started
vega we really sort of expected to have
to do a lot more to prove it worked and
a lot more
you know of that groundwork to get money
in and actually what's happened in d5 in
the last couple of years is people have
shown a
you know feracious appetite to to come
in and just start trading these things
and using them and
evaluating them in production i think
that's that's really cool because it
means we can move really fast and
develop new stuff
when we go to and i always ask everyone
the same three questions
and then you'll get to ask me one
question at the end uh the first
question is just what's the most
important book that you've ever read
the most important book i've ever read
that is uh
most the one i always quote is the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy so um
i'm
gonna have to go with that one why that
one
um i i think i mean i found it um
found it incredibly incredibly fun and
it made me sort of think about things in
a very different way
the other book which i'm gonna gonna
name here is perhaps more important
directly sort of relevant is things like
snow crash
um and some other kind of you know
william gibson and another cyberpunk
because i
tend to think those kind of sci-fi
things in general and the hitchhiker's
guide to galaxy 2 they kind of teach you
things about the future they teach you
the ways things could be and
ways things might happen and ways people
might interact and i find that really
helpful and really helps me sort of
design new things i love that answer
uh second question comes from our
friends over at sleep they've got this
thermo-regulated bed that essentially
allows you to
turn it really hot really cold i sleep
on it super cold used to only sleep like
five or six hours now i sleep eight or
nine
absolutely life-changing what's your
sleep schedule
and how has that changed over the years
um yeah so i try to get a decent amount
of sleep when i can
um it doesn't always work but i tend to
think sleep is good
one of the things when i sort of started
working not exactly for myself but you
know starting companies and
working with teams where i have more
flexibility was to kind of
try and institute a schedule where it
was rare to wake up to an alarm so you
know if you can kind of get your
sleep shed you're working so you kind of
got a you've got an alarm of last resort
but actually you're going to wake up
naturally with the sun or whatever i
find it
in much better relaxation and uh and
yeah i also like a
super cold bed that's the best way to be
last question then you get asked me one
is aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
yeah i mean i certainly believe there's
life out there um
i don't know whether it's intelligent
and i'm really unsure that it's visited
us but i certainly believe there's
there's more life forms than just on
this planet in the universe
uh yeah i tend to agree do you think
we'll get to them or we'll contact them
i don't know not in my lifetime i
suspect
i i i am right there with you i think
that they're probably out there but uh
probably too far away
what one question down there there
what's the one question you have for me
to finish up question i have for you
um you know i guess what's the um
you know of all of the kind of all of
the kind of sort of ideologies and
reasons you know
why we're in this space and why we're
doing you know what we're doing at vega
and other people doing it what's the one
that resonates the most with you and why
i think it's just giving power back to
people right just returning kind of
freedom and power back to the everyday
person and
i'm not one of these folks who uh i
would put in like the anarchist category
of like we have to take down the entire
system and
completely build from scratch uh i think
that there
is a way to acknowledge in a very
rational and optimistic way
some of the legacy system can be
valuable
and can actually provide incredible
benefit to people
both organizations and individuals at
the same
time there's a lot that needs to change
and be improved frankly
it's not just change for changes fake
it's actually about
improvement and creating human progress
and being able to increase human
productivity and happiness
and so i think that's probably the thing
of just the philosophical belief
that we can use technology to return
power
control freedom and ultimately happiness
back to people
and do so in a very non-violent way
right historically for that to happen
you'd have to have some sort of violent
conflict
between warring nation-states or
communities
in this case you're able to do it in a
very kind of passive
way so i think that's actually a really
interesting
kind of development through all of this
and one that just resonates
how awesome couldn't agree more where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or find more about what you
guys are building
yeah you can find more at vega.xyz
or our twitter has vega protocol
awesome barney listen thank you so much
for doing this i think it's fascinating
to learn more about kind of
decentralized derivatives for everyone
who listened to uh learned more as well
and we'll do it again in the future
brilliant great to be on thanks for
having me